what about exotic blueprints guys Tzadik
blueprint so it can go to your left or
right here yeah
so these terminals here down in the Hall
of guardians are your exotic blueprint
collections and what an exotic blueprint
is is it's a record of having found one
of these exotics in year one or in year
two so if you open up that terminal
you'll see the different exotics that
you've found and added to your
collection okay so every time you find
an exotic the blueprint is added to this
collection and what these collections
are here for is you know if you misplace
an exotic or you like dog steps on my
dog's steps on the controller for ten
whole seconds and chards it my fiancé
thinks I play too much destiny lands
vengefully like yours you don't need
this that's hopefully that might be on
them don't get into those those personal
problems this uh this is a place where
you can actually just come back here and
pull another one of these out of the
vault and you know get back what you may
have lost okay I like to think of this
as like the Star Trek replicator but
instead of ordering hot tea like you're
asking for Plan C and you get like a new
one I'd see hot yes yeah the other
useful thing here is if you've got an
alt and you just want to get a copy of
that thing for an alt character you can
just go to the blue print keep these are
account-based yes these are all
account-wide okay so all of the
characters I have on one account can
access all the blueprints get across all
of those separate adventures
so let's actually talk a little bit
about the exotics themselves so this is
light beyond nemesis I'm serious this is
gear one
yeah it's giving you the perk that lets
you revive people faster yeah but you
know you have to spend a bunch of time
and resources like loving this update up
I really I'm saying it was valuable
until you get here yeah and even then
there's still got work to do yeah so in
year two we've actually taken some of
the year one exotics some favorites and
we've we've upgraded them we've made
them better so that not only can you
still get them but they're improved so
if you switch over to this page so here
is the light beyond nemesis version for
destiny to take and King this is the
year to light beyond nemesis now I see
here there are some other engrams here
there are some other exotics for me to
change
yeah because I already acquired life
beyond nemesis that's right because he
has a blueprint they're just gonna give
it to me
yeah so any of the year one exotics that
you have found any of those that are
available in year two are available
right here on the blueprint so I go on I
just got it does cause some legendary
much yes down some like let's drill in
and you'll see why okay so these are
improved not only in level but the
exotic armor we've taken the signature
perk
yeah we've moved it on to intrinsic so
the keeper the pack the thing that lets
me revive my friends faster the reason I
got the helmet the reason why I upgraded
that helmet after I got it that's active
now that's an X I admire the helmet the
thing that made it great is already live
yeah you can even try these exotics out
much more easily now and when you level
them up they start at the max power just
like they did in house of wolves so
we're really trying to make it so that
when you get an exotic you know you can
just use it you know just enjoy it right
away well then you got some new ways to
upgrade it I'm not just making it more
powerful and adding new talents to this
helmet yeah so there's new talents
available on a lot of these exotics so
this one for example is inversed shadow
here and right down below it is a new
perk that increases the super energy you
gain when you're getting heavy weapon
kills yeah so and so I'm excited about
this for my you know for weapons as well
because I have the bad juju exotic
bounty quest right now and haven't
finished it yet
but I'm almost there I'm gonna finish it
probably the next couple weeks okay and
you know because I work at Bungie I know
that level 40 bad juju is coming out in
September and so I'm going to have
immediate access to be able to get that
thing you know and I'm probably going to
be able to actually use it because I
haven't I haven't earned it yet but I'm
once I earn it I'm half of the blueprint
I'm going to be able to buy that level
forty version and so I'm already
spending my you know legendary marks in
my head like that's the one of the first
things that I'm gonna chase yeah so can
I go here yeah tonight tonight let's go
in there so we didn't want to be the
case that if you found something in year
one yeah that you had to go and find it
again in year two so that's why that's
why the blueprints give you access to
the updated versions of any of the Year
one items but you're only bringing some
of those exotics forward yeah only some
of them are coming forward right now and
but any exotic that we bring forward
yeah there will be the updated for
versions available here in the bloops
you can see my collection here I earned
truth eyes our Galler horn along with
lots of people they will give you stats
in the Bungie weekly update never really
took a stab at Dragon's Breath but I do
love my heavies so you know if you're if
you're more of a completionist than me
you can come in here and and gaze upon
your treasures and and then buy back a
new version of those if at such a time
you know I say you know what I want to
give universal remote a second chance or
you know I remember back in the day you
know like suros regime you know at the
launch of destiny first iron banner
suros regime was an absolute terror it
was the thorn of its day and then you
know it got adjusted but with the two da
no weapon update auto rifles are coming
back in a big way so I always loved
suros so let's look at the updated
version of saros along with again here
are all of these missing engrams all of
these new things to chase all of these
just you know imagine if you will all of
these year to exotic weapons you know
what's going to be the next Red Death
what's going to be the next Gjallarhorn
what's going to be the next thorn or
last word and I got the suros regime so
the service regime here updated its
different take just a little bit so that
it follows what the rest of the service
foundry weapons do and for example in
this case you can choose between these
first two fires
fast that's awesome because I actually
like saw rose before I upgraded it and
it turned you know was given a slower
rate of fire so I can make it fire
faster yup and then gives me my health
back yep I can make it more accurate
that's awesome
yeah and check this out it's back in
black that is sexy it's like Darth
Vader's Ferrari right there I want it I
want it and I don't have to go out and I
don't have to worry about it dropping I
don't have to wait for to sell it to me
that's right it's here I have the
upgraded blueprint on grandfathered in
this is where I'm going to be spending
my first legendary marks yep if you
found it in year one we want to make
sure that you have it in year two cool
could you just go back in there for a
second I noticed something that we
didn't talk about her there and that
they attack values on the year one
weapons
has changed okay you look at Soros's 160
here well yeah Tyson Kenya yes so we
took the we took all the values on the
attack values in the defense values and
we we brought them all in line with each
other so that you can look at a 160
weapon and compare it to a 160 helmet
and sort of know that you're dealing
with the same quality of item and we
actually we use the current value that
people have on their armor their light
value which is about 168 and that's sort
of where we we set our midpoint and then
we balanced everything around that so
people actually haven't lost any
effectiveness make sure you know it
whatever you can kill with zero so
September 14th
he'll it's just as hard in September 15
just math like their numbers have just
changed your guns hit just as hard and
your armor is just as good at protecting
you so yep like we switched over to the
metric system yes okay the superior
system impact the superior wokai the
superior metrics
you